the final celebrity to give evidence in
the max Clipper trial was des O'Connor
the former chat show host came to court
and told the jury that the celebrity
publicists that he had known through the
years had always acted with honesty and
integrity and then proceeded a cottage
QC for the prosecution began her closing
speech this is the start of the final
stages of this trial and she reminded
the jury of just how serious the sexual
allegations are that Max Clifford faces
and the very big deal that it has been
for the women who have come to court to
give often very personal and very
intimate details of their alleged
experiences with Max Clifford she said
to the jury they've not come to court to
lie you have seen what's gone on in this
courtroom you can tell who is lying and
she went on to say it is not fun
standing there being accused of being a
fanta cyst or a liar
we also heard more evidence surrounding
max Clifford's intimate size details and
once again
Rosina cottage QC said to the jury that
it is not important the size it is what
he has done with it